mais bon
diane dufresne brise encore des tabous
sur son quatorzième album studio ou sans
détour elle chante son propre
vieillissement les suivons une vieille
personne citoyenne quant à 74 ans pour
rien parce que c'est ça parce que
personne n'en parle et que je me suis
dit moi je me regarde dans un miroir je
ne reconnais pas
si mon corps
en disgrâce
quand on parle de la vieillesse est
quelque chose qui s'appelle j'avais
raison d'avoir peur c'est un bon mois
qui avaient mon âge bien avant
dans la voir là
même si elle vieillit la chanteuse a
toujours voulu se renouveler pour son
disque baptisé meilleur après elle s'est
entouré de jeunes musiciens
ajoutez à cela daniel bélanger qui lui a
offert une chanson émis ce qui nous
détruit et bizarre
on veut tous est un miel daniel bélanger
quand daniel bélanger et là on est en
sécurité quand les gens aiment daniel
bélanger on sait que le monde vaut bien
celle qui chantait une certaine époque
j'ai rencontré l'homme de ma vie
les soucis place à l'amour sur son
disque inspiré par richard langevin sang
congelé depuis plus de 20 ans
la nomme kamel qui épouse une femme dix
ans plus âgé que lui et quand les chats
rentrer à la maison tous les jours que
j'ai je suis ému je suis ni de le revoir
[Musique]
pour diane dufresne ce nouveau disque
était une sorte de passage obligé pour
faire ce qu'elle aime vraiment je ne
profère désisté je me passerais j'aime
pas entrer dans ce processus
d'indépendance totale avec d autres
comme ça on lit sur scène il ya une
espèce de liberté moi je fais ça pour
aller sur cinq la scène l'appel
justement à l'automne 2010 9
diane dufresne offrira une série de
concerts avec trois orchestres
symphoniques différents à montréal
québec et ottawa